earlier this week Australia's richest
literary prize was awarded for a book
written by text message the author is
this man they rose Bhushan II he's a
Kurdish Iranian refugee who detailed the
despair of his many years in limbo
inside an Australian offshore detention
center he wasn't allowed to attend the
ceremony in Melbourne to pick up his
prize he told D udw however that
receiving the award has been bittersweet
it is a big achievement for me for the
refugees on Manus Island and model and
also for all of the refugees and you
know stateless people around the world
and I myself still I mean living in this
island and we have lost many things over
the past six years and that's why I
think I I cannot have celebration I
cannot celebrate my you know you this
award and this achievement as author and
refugee Baraboo Changi there and with me
here is DW reporter Jared Reed tell us
more about this man sober is bhishan II
is a Kurdish journalist who fled Iran
some years ago and sought refuge in
Australia he arrived there by boat but
due to Australia's hardline immigration
policies he was sent to a detention
center outside of Australia's borders
and in this case it is called Manus
Island it's an island administered by
Papua New Guinea and Bhutan II has been
there since 2013 in the years since then
he's become one of the best-known voices
from inside Australia's offshore
detention system describing quite often
on Twitter and online what he says are
inhumane conditions and human rights
abuses committed there these pictures
we're looking at are from the
documentary he was able to shoot using
his phone inside the manor centre and he
wrote the book on his phone that's right
he he typed it out by a text message and
sent it through the the service whatsapp
to a translator in Australia and these
are some of the chunks of text that he
sent these screenshots were sent to us
by the translator a mid to figure on
bhishan 'i was worried guards would take
his writing which is why he just kind of
wanted to get it out and send it to his
translator as soon as he could and these
texts became this book here it's called
no friend but the mountains writing from
Manas prison which burrows by Shani
himself describes as the product of
years of imprisonment and systematic
torture both on him and other refugees
and what he's talking about there are
the stories coming that have come out of
Manas Island and nayru another Pacific
island where Australian has a detention
center of human rights abuses being
committed so so refugees harming
themselves of living in very poor
conditions of riots so Bush on e1 this
very rich prize around 60,000 euros
worth but he wasn't able to attend the
ceremony to get the award because of
Australian law that's right so Australia
when it comes to asylum seekers who
arrived by boat Australia refuses to
settle them in Australia it puts them
offshore for processing and then tries
to resettle them in a third country and
Australian the government says well this
is to deter people coming by boat
because the journey is dangerous and
largely it's worked because asylum
arrivals by boat have basically stopped
but it's as you can imagine being hugely
controversial not least for the effects
on children there have been many
children in these centres there's been a
huge push to get them out of the end
their families out of the detention
centres and into other accommodations so
many have been settled in places like
the u.s. some of these children have had
quite devastating psychological effects
from their years in detention in terms
of burrows bhishan II he he still has to
be on Manus the the the centre where he
wrote the book closed in 2017 and he's
been in other accommodation but
basically since then has just been
waiting to find out where he'll be able
to go if you'll be able to go anywhere
so more of a wait for him unfortunately
incredible to think of art being created
in such conditions Thank You Jared
you